have you ever felt that
creepy sensation of bugs crawling on
your skin
in the middle of the night don't worry
it's
probably all in your mind but it could
actually be spiders
what if you happen to swallow one
should you be worried would a spider
survive inside a human body
what would happen if you ingested a
venomous spider
could they lay their eggs in you
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a spider entered your body
chances are some annoying friend of
yours has
told you that humans swallow on average
eight spiders every year
well i hate to break it to you but your
friend's right
oh the good news is most of the time
spiders will die on the way down and you
get a little protein boost
they're also rich in folic acid and zinc
so
think of it as a healthy late night
snack
as creepy as all this sounds there's no
need to worry
unless you're suffering from
arachnophobia or
even worse delusory parasitosis
known commonly as ekbomb syndrome this
rare psychological condition provokes
the delusional fear
of being infested by an insect
sufferers of ekbomb syndrome can often
feel itchiness
numbness or that creepy crawly prickling
sensation under their skin
well if bugs crawling on you is just a
delusion
could a real spider actually survive
inside you generally
spiders won't target humans unless they
feel threatened
but what if one just happens to fall in
your mouth
could it poison you well
despite popular belief there's no such
thing as
a poisonous spider simply put
eating them is not toxic to us in fact
in some cultures
fried spiders are a delicacy
okay eight-legged snacks aside what if a
venomous spider happened to make its way
inside you
could it kill you
[Music]
there are around 40 000 species of
spider and
only 12 of them can cause serious harm
to humans
take for instance the highly venomous
sydney funnel web spider or
atrax robustus they can grow up to five
centimeters long with
fangs strong enough to bite through a
fingernail
so much for that manicure
they're also clingy and like to dig in
to ensure their venom
enters the bloodstream of their prey
to make matters worse they've been known
to survive underwater for
up to 30 hours
well as resilient as they are thankfully
our stomachs are far more acidic than
water and
even a venomous spider is no match for
that powerful gut of yours
unless of course it happens to latch
onto your esophagus on the way down
then you would need about two to twelve
anti-venom injections
depending on the severity of your
symptoms
there's also the slight chance that
you're allergic to them in which
case i'd keep that epipen in close reach
luckily venom can only affect you if
it's injected so
even venomous spiders are safe to
accidentally consume
[Music]
so what if a spider decides to lay eggs
in your ear
well this is highly unlikely so you can
take those ear muffs off
even if you did find a nest all you'd
have to do is
rinse them out spiders burrowing in
humans
is a popular urban legend but in reality
they're more likely to avoid you so
don't expect any superpowers overnight
even if they somehow managed to set up
shop in your ear
once the baby spiders hatched they would
probably leave your body in search of
food
not exactly a pleasant experience but
nothing a good shower can't fix
so you might be asking yourself should i
wear a bug net while i sleep
well there's really no need spiders can
sense danger through vibrations
and we produce a lot of noise
this spidey sense would likely trigger
if you're snoring like a chainsaw or
even peacefully breathing thankfully
your noisy slumber will likely deter
them
even if you sleep with your mouth open
if a spider managed
to crawl in you would probably just
cough really hard and kill them in the
process
so the good news is spiders simply can't
survive inside of you
they are far more likely to hang out in
dark and secluded areas that
aren't a part of your body
with that said it might be time to clean
out that closet of yours
better safe than sorry
okay okay i know what you're thinking
can't we just get
rid of them for good well believe it or
not
spiders are vital creatures in our
ecosystem
what would life be like without them
well i have an
itsy-bitsy feeling that that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
you